all right y'all wild 9041 bass party
station bootleg cab in studio we got a
hot new group signed by Mike will made
it
whoa ray shimmered sure I get that right
yeah yeah right now yeah Burt wait
forever okay listen
so it's to you guys it sounds like Rae
sremmurd should be one dude yeah what is
what man it's like we were in Tupelo we
went by a different name
yeah but we ended up coming to Atlanta
with the air drummers which is Mike
wheels production company they put us on
so we hit we got together like how can
we come up with a with a name like as
one and that's actually air drummers
backwards Oh sir I see Majoris very
Sherman so were you guys originally from
Mississippi Tupelo Mississippi oh okay
Mississippi shot David Banner who else
is from Mississippi
Creek Creek great of course won my favor
artists on the way to think that first
that's what's up man so um you guys uh
got like one of the biggest producers in
the game behind you Mike will made it
how did that situation gonna be I know
you guys were on his mixtape with a Mike
Wolfe in trail yeah we had that we on
there yeah he had on it he actually
brought us to Atlanta we did some work
with the air drummers and he got to hear
some of those songs and he liked them so
we're the ear drummers so what P nasty
Mars a blade slice that's how you girls
roots yeah okay so you guys came to
Atlanta started working with Mike and
then he got his label situation guys are
the first artists on this label right
that's a big - nine - nine did the truth
yeah all right so how are you did you
guys look like you might be 13 for 30
I'm 44 now after the we just incognito
it's a so we just let people think
whatever they want however
okay oh they want it to be you know
saying krinkle willing to close
I just had our promotions check come in
here and she is white as all hell yeah
and she said what does that mean like
you can't flex muscles like explain what
no flex oh it is to the lovely
Caucasians of Tampa
like it's like like suppose like suppose
I just came in like I had the brand noon
I had the brand-new Jordans on you
listen somebody else comes in with like
some Wallabies out or something he's
like that's close miss killer some
busted Wallabies
shoes ain't nothing man off legs on the
flakes right now can't flex oh man you
know somebody like they broke as a mug
and I know you can't come in here with
so Mike's
Everlast joints on from Kmart and try
flexing no you can come in it just be a
matter how you saw sit though you gotta
have a sauce man us on laying shirts in
sauce so alright so you can't flex in
garbage sneakers around these guys not
really know what you're saying don't
flake Hills just you don't hate on
nobody hate do your own thing man ain't
got a lot of keep all right so you have
to see what we see was gaining some buzz
I know uh I was with Katie and Keith
loves that damn song he was Wiz loves
the song um
what is next like well are you is this
gonna be a part of a album IEP iTunes
deal was we gotta drop in real soon it's
kind of like some big features on it
yeah it's gonna crank everything look we
got enough legs on I don't buy it
were you guys fit in with like you know
it's it's a it's a very ATL sounding
record you know I'm saying so where do
you guys think you fit in when it when
it comes to all amigos and no way to fit
it with none that we try that we
actually turn the Creator ahold like our
whole another lane like when when like
all of our music drops like it's just
like it's a new lane is it all turn up
is nice we got it we got other words we
got this Liz party look now we got all
kind of different difference that we
make all but most of them is gonna be on
the album and what part of Mississippi
you guys from - OH
it's something I've never heard of yeah
look smart city shout out to Mississippi
shout out to these guys make sure you
what your answers Twitter and Instagram
yup check us out on twitter IG rae
sremmurd ra e sr e mm u ID sunlight you
guys share the account together like you
know yeah they've got we got
personalized to my h2o underscore lean
you can catch me on JX m in my answer
question if a bad [__] like baby M's
you on on the group instagram right how
do you guys you know we chill in real
life and they like let's say a top-notch
thought yeah dmg guys right like i'm
very well plays on all of your face so
let's say this happens and you guys both
or like joe yeah or or way still to
bring a friend you know an inch renergie
the name always good let's bring a group
of areas where those WWE Tag Team
Champions baby oh yeah that's what it is
yo check so how about a man go get him
out on that Instagram go by this single
and yeah we gonna play right now so I'm
94 1 sure life
no flick